اسبوعان من المفاوضات الساخنه بعيدا عن
وسائل الاعلام بين اعضاء اللجنه المكلفه
من مجلس النواب والمجلس الاعلى يتوجان في
اعلان التوصل الى صياغه القوانين
الانتخابيه
بحضور سفراء لعدد من الدول اعلنت اللجنه
ان اعضائها نجحوا في التوافق على قانون
يتعلق بانتخاب اعضاء مجلسي النواب والشيوخ
بالاضافه الى قانون يتعلق بانتخاب رئيس
البلاد
انتخابات مجلس الامه الذي يتكون من غرفتين
مجلس النواب ومجلس الشيوخ كما تم الاتفاق
على قانون انتخاب رئيس الدوله
وقد كانت الاتفاقات حول النقاط العالقه
كلها تمت بتوافق تام
رغم وصول رئيس المجلس الاعلى للدوله خالد
المصري ورئيسي مجلس النواب عقيل صالح الى
مدينه بوزنيقه الى ان الرجلين لم يشارك في
المؤتمر الصحفي الذي تاخر لساعات لكن
عودتهما ستكون قريبه لتوقيع الاتفاق بحسب
اللجنه ننتظر في الايام القادمه
[موسيقى]
حضور السيد رئيس مجلس النواب ورئيس مجلس
الدوله
التوقيع او
البث في
الاتفاق النهائي المغرب الذي استضاف
الاجتماعات اشاد بالتوافقات التي توصلت
اليها اللجنه ودعا الى توفير الدعم
لليبيين وقع خلال هذه الايام الاخيره
بمدينه بوزنيقه هو تطور مهم وتطور اساسي
ويبشر بالخير ان شاء الله
محتاج بطبيعه الحال هذا التوافقات محتاجه
الى مواكبه
لتدقيق بعض امورها
خلال اسبوعين من التفاوت ساعه اللجنه
المعروفه بسته زائد سته الى توفير القاعده
الانتخابيه التي حاله الخلافات بشانها دون
تنظيم ليبيا للانتخابات خلال السنوات
الماضيه حققت اللجنه المعروفه بسته زائد
سته تقدما في مسار انجاز القوانين
الانتخابيه وفي انتظار ان تتضح كافه
تفاصيل تلك القوانين ستحدد ردود الفعل
المختلفه مصيره اجراء الانتخابات الليبيه
المختاره العلاوي الجزيره مدينه بوزنيقه